okay so thank you for the organizers for
giving me this chance to give a talk
organizer
actually the motivation for this work is
partially your work with john so
it's a paper uh by john hanson and frank
sotile in
in
2011 that they certify
they they act it's like a program
package and a paper coming with it it
certifies square systems polynomial
system and
polynomials in n variables using alpha
theory
so
in general alpha theory developed by
steve smell and mike shope
use gives a formula using derivatives of
the of the functions and and the
coordinates of your approximate point
that you want to certified
and
and you plug it in and it gives a proof
that
from your point newton method
quadratically converges to a root of the
system
this only works for simple roots and in
fact you also certify that
between your approximation and the exact
route there are no other routes of the
system
and it also you can also use it to give
a bound on the distance from the exact
route so what's new about this paper of
my understanding of it is that they give
a very easily computable
bound for the alpha
function in case of polynomial system
and they implement it and they use it
for certifying polynomial systems
so uh
to get from square system to over
determine systems it's a big jump there
are a lot of difficulties so
there is a alpha theory
uh developed uh by lydia and chubb uh
for over-determined systems
uh but we couldn't use that and the
reason is because that would certify
fixed point for the gauss newton
iteration but those thick points do not
correspond always with roots
and the other big jump in the notion is
that really consistency of
over-determined systems is not a
continuous property we are not
interested in this talk of certifying
whether you can perturb your input
system and then find the root we really
want the root of the input system so for
example if you don't know the
coefficients exactly only in an interval
of your input system the question
doesn't even make sense so this simple
system
if you don't know the exact value of a
you cannot decide whether it has a root
or not so
that is the reason that the question
that you're trying to answer only makes
sense over the rationals you can also
extend it for algebraic extension but
that eventually reduces to the rational
case
so in the same paper of frank and john
they actually studies this same question
and they give a
certification algorithm to certify that
something is not an approximate
route using alpha theory so basically
the idea is the following
is that they take two
random
square subsystem of the overdetermined
system they are just linear random
linear combinations and they use
homotopic method to solve them
and then they
with
alpha theory for each of these random
square system they could certify that
the point that they want to certify um
is a approximate route if they find it
for one of them it's not
case closed it was not a approximate
route for the full system however if
they are
you can certify that the corresponding
routes are not equal by getting
more and more accurate
approximation of the roots
until with using each of these square
system until you have this
inequality
so here we don't know the roots but with
of us here you can get a bound on the
right hand side and this would prove
basically that that the corresponding
root cannot be the same point
yeah
so this is using office theory to prove
that they that your point is not an
exact not a a root an approximate root
uh to certify
the opposite that you are actually near
an exact route they basically propose to
use
a priori worst case lower bounds for
rational polynomial systems
which are known to be positive over a
disk
and in the paper they conclude that
these known lower bounds are
in the worst case lower bands are too
small to be practical
so is the point we're wrong no
so here's here is the simplest version
of this
theorem go back to kenny in 87
and
and he gives you can see that
these lower bounds are well they're the
size of them are exponential right so
the magnitude is double exponential and
a very simple example shows that in the
worst case
you can actually get that so here
this system is n plus 1 polynomials in n
variable the height of this polynomial
is at most two the degree is also two
and
they don't have a common root but
the
last
or the extra polynomial can have
such a double exponentially small value
um
on
on the roots of the the previous
polynomial so
yeah for
using worst case lower bounds we cannot
hope to get
too much better
so what what we did
is that
i looked at these um papers of they oh i
forgot to say there is in the audience a
lot of several people who who actually
work this is a a lot of work has been
done to finding these uh
lower bounds and extensions and
different cases
um
so what i found and i may be
not completely uh right about it that
most of them reduce the the problem to
the univariate case either by
considering rational universe
representation or other kind of rational
representations
which are all really computable objects
like these papers use computable objects
and then to
then they use worst case height bonds
and univariate through separation bounds
to give the worst case flow around
so the main idea of this work is that
why don't we compute those objects for
our system instead of using these very
pessimistic
um lower ones so that's the main idea
and so the goal and the results what we
achieved there are many choices to do
that as we
figure that basically what you have to
do
uh so first of all as i mentioned this
uh but the certificate that we want to
give is for a property that is not
continuous so
the certification
necessarily has to have some exact
computation you will have at one point
decide to decide something x equal to
zero a number equal exactly to zero so
it we we cannot hope to to use a fully
numerical algorithm so what we propose
here
is a mixed
hybrid symbolic numeric method
uh which is better than the worst case
one so most of the sim you could go just
in using symbolic methods then you would
get the worst case bound but what we're
trying to prove that mixing symbolic and
numeric techniques
with not
too much extra
computation compared to the homotopic
continuation method you can actually
also compute a certificate so we take
homotopic continuation method as kind of
something that you can do so we assume
that for a square subsystem you can
compute all the root and then a little
extra computation gives you also a
certificate for
the over constraint system
and then the second part of the talk i
will
talk about how to reduce
the certification of singular roots
to the previous case for the
over-determined case
so that's the outline of the rest of the
talk
so um
so first the over determined system and
i'm not gonna give you the whole
algorithm it's very simple as i said
there are many choices so basically what
we try to avoid is you there is
literature you could use for example
the lll
algorithm to create a rational
representation we try to avoid that
because that doesn't parallelize we
wanted to find an algorithm that just
like homotopic method you can compute
with many processors parallels so
so this is maybe the simplest such
representation that you can do there
might be better ones but we did our
complexity analysis for this particular
simple representation
and i saw it on this toy example
so this is three equations in two
variables and it's corresponding really
already to the double root case so it's
the intersection this of this
circle with a parabola
and
we are interested in this
in the two
double points
so the third equation is just the
determinant of the jacobian of the first
two
so the first step
is to use homotopy method for a random
square subsystem same as in the paper of
john and frank
um
and we have four
single roots
with no multiplicity and then the second
step is um
plug in back or use your favorite method
to exclude the routes that surely not
gonna satisfy your over constraint
system so among the four two will be
candidates
of uh
of satisfying all these three equations
and we get some
numerical approximation so the main
point here that these approximations
we cannot hope to find exactly they are
from an algebraic extension in
particular the second coordinate will be
one force but the first happens to be
not one it is a proper algebraic
extension however what we do instead
is we combine them and get from these
two
roots
they will form a rational component and
we can find a representation which then
have rational
coefficient
so basically we use the what is called
the rational univariate representation
again i you could use your favorite
representation rational representation
um the first part is so-called primitive
element it's a linear combination of the
coordinates that separates the root this
is the
defining equation of your primitive
element and then these ones are just
interpolate the coordinates in the
primitive elements it's a very simple
representation
and so the first one is not the true
exact
uh it's just uh what you get from the
first
approximation so the
the
then you have to use some technique to
refine
the accuracy and we give several
techniques basically based on hence a
lemma you can do it or just brute force
interpolation and newton's method
until
you get the exact one and this is where
you check with exact
the exact arithmetic that something is
zero
yes so checking whether you found the
right thing
is an exact
uh computation and can be easily done
so and then
finally
now once you've found the exact
representation
you just use of a certified for now this
square system to certify the roots
so in other words
from approximate roots we construct a
approximate rational representation and
that one we can find actually exactly by
refining it that's the main idea it's
reconstructing a rational representation
from approximate data
is there is there you are the right
there yeah so that so you have solutions
to that yes so so it may be a subset of
the the original set but but
when you choose these points
you have some these approximate points
you have some control to include the one
that you want to certify to start with
so the main results what we proved with
this very simple algorithm are the
complexity results so the first one is
that each iteration
can be efficiently parallelized
so
the in an
um where we use an uh arithmetic
parallel complexity model so it will be
the square of the logarithm of the depth
of the polarization with polynomially
many processors
and the second one and this is the
the
like a simplified version is basically
the main point of this doing all this so
in in the best case when we actually
find a rational
representation
the algorithm is polynomial in the
output size and not the first case size
and and that's why so basically you
gain
uh when your system
is better than the worst case so it's
not a
degenerate case
then you can actually find it much
faster than using either symbolic
methods or the
the worst case binds that
john and frank uses and then finally we
also study the worst case
or
when you actually fail it happens that
you fail and hopefully you never get
into that situation
using the method of disproving of uh
john and frank you can actually detect
when you chose the wrong point so
hopefully you will never get getting
this point but this is actually
according to the worst case uh that
other people use or what you would get
with only symbolic method so the the
the
moral is that that you get an early term
terminating algorithm if you combine
numerical and symbolic techniques
so the second part is to use this
um
in
certifying iso singular points so there
were several people mentioning these
uh algorithms so or these techniques um
so
here the problem is the similar we are
given a point
and the polynomial system which is not
going to be the constraint under
constraint over constraint and we want
to certify that
the point is an approximation of an iso
singular point and instead of defining
iso singular points
um i just give this example
so if
so we do not require that it's an
isolated root of the original system so
for example if the original system
consists of this single polynomial then
the origin
will be an isolate is a non-isolated
root
but it's an isolated root of the
deflated system so here the the jacobian
matrix that at the origin we have rank
zero so you just
add the
one times one sub matrices and the
determinants of them uh append it to the
system and i will show you so using
this iso singular deflation
you deflate it and then for the deflated
system you have an isolated simple route
that then you have an iso singular point
we will use the
same similar deflation methods that
other people use and you have seen
today several times
and i we call this to determinate
deflations there are again other choices
we happen to choose this one because it
has some properties that we like so
basically you append to the original
system
sub miners of the jacobian matrix and
you find those sub miners by
having an
approximation of your
iso singular root you can detect the
maximal non-singular
minor and then you just take
the minors that contain that so you can
make this
not too many so you can make it just
polynomially money
and you can either iterate this
we assume i think this method would not
work if you don't assume that the number
of i iteration of this deflation is too
big maybe one or two times you can
iterate the degrees of these polynomials
um are
decreasing heavily
but in theory it's possible to to all
this so what we like about this that you
get an over constraint system it's a
rational system you don't use really
your approximate root or root
coordinates anywhere
and
the number of variables did not increase
so the heaviest part of the computation
the homotopy method we have the same
number of n variables and just the
degree of the polynomials increase
though but
other there are other maybe this is not
the best but for our purpose is to
demonstrate that the algorithm works
um
it's a
itself is to use this one
so um
so and then
you just use the machinery that i talked
about you have now an over determined
system that has
your
original singular point now is
non-singular for this system
and
you can certify it it's an over
determined system
so let me finish the talk with examples
um so the first one is called the
compress system it's a
one of the benchmark problems that
people try to use and i and we try to
find examples when actually the roots
are not rational so you really need to
find the rational
representation the roots alone wouldn't
give a certificate
and
so this system has 24
nonsing or like simple roots and eight
multiple roots and each multiple root
has the jacobian with rank two so
the deflation appends four
three by three sub determinants
and then we get an over
determined system that now have the
eight roots
and
then we can compute
this rational univariate representation
which certifies them
um
the second example is uh
is well
it's uh called the cyclic n system
because you cycle around the variable in
these products
and again this is
considered
hard to solve because of the high number
of
singular roots and also the
same
symmetries in the solution
and again it has for any graph four
it has eight
singular isosingular points
and then using this just one step of the
deflation
we get um
we deflated them and then you can
certify them with the over constrained
certifier
so this is again the
the rational univariate representation
that you can compute exactly
and then finally for the
uh the cyclic nine
system
little bit modified have now
54 regular and 54 double roots and then
these double roots actually split up
into three subsets depending which
sub determinant
of the jacobian matrix is non-singular
and then for each of them you can find
the rational representation
so
um just what we are doing now so um
the first two here is what i talked
about so well
the over determining system and the iso
singular point certification what i
talked about and um the implementation
of the over-determined system
certification algorithm
is
easy under consumption our student um
tuli is working on it right now
um
in preparation video with a
collaboration with also with bernard
moran um we are working on
also trying to certify
the multiplicity structure not only the
root itself and its coordinates but the
multiplicity structure so we have a
we are working on a paper on it and we
haven't yet start to work but that's in
the plans to deal with higher
dimensional components
thank you for your time
my question is not actually about your
results but uh
about these bad examples so you you
showed us an an example uh
where you have a
uh there is no separation between the
rules yeah
can you
my feeling was that all all these
examples with a very uh
that separation are very degenerate in
some sense
uh
so if you look at this example it looks
like it's not degenerate at all because
all the
seem to be isolated and simple um
but uh
so
if you so if
you look at what happens at infinity i
don't remember this very well now but i
think if you look in projective space
then
the system is actually
not so nice to have
i forget what happens but
that in in the
general case you would have this kind of
situation
i'd like to know if it's known
that for a non-degenerate system then
would be true that you have better
bounds than
well you have to define what is
non-design because here it's these are
already special systems that you want to
certify right you want to certify
over-determined system which are
consistent so then within them
so i mean that if you i guess
multiple
solutions
yeah if you if you have any
solutions uh
in projective space and no
multiplicities uh but if your job is
that somebody gives you you don't have
that no i i listen that
what you do is probably more efficient
but uh
i'm just curious
whether better bonds than this are
available
in non-degenerate situations
if it's true to hook up the systems it's
a hard problem right
is there about that hard problem
oh it wasn't there
so
it's probably true that they are very
special in some sense
you are not aware of any
research around what's wrong
i don't know
well here let's talk about that what
does charles have to say i have two
questions my first one is on the iso
singular deflation part of course
we discover the rank that we use to form
the
from using the approximation in the
numerically approximated solution
and it's possible to get that rank wrong
would your procedure
realize that and then uh
um
well
um okay so so your question is that here
here right that um
that we assume that we know
the maxima minor
yes it no i don't think so i think you
would get into the the situation
okay
so if you don't get the rank right yeah
then you haven't deflated it and it'll
still be singular and so then your
newton
method won't converge
so you'll see
that if agnes flips one way or the other
you start with some approximation of the
uh
earlier keep going
there
so you start with some approximation of
the rur yeah and if everything is
non-singular then you'll converge to
this one with uh rational points
if you get the rank wrong you won't see
the convergence here
okay
and
is there a test for how
so so this is what i mentioned that that
yes you this is so to exclude the wrong
choices
with this method
unfortunately you have to use these
worst case bounds
but but i mentioned and that's just a
heuristic that this is the case that
actually alpha theory handles more
efficiently by by the method of john and
frank so
so hopefully combining the two
two ways of
of uh
seeing whether you you chose the wrong
point or wrong rank
you could use then uh john and frank's
method and offer theory to detect it
before you have to go through all these
computation
um to to certify and figure that you did
the wrong choice okay and then my other
question was
uh you have to put some roots together
in order to get the right
so
is that a combinatorial problem figuring
out which ones belong together yeah so
so there are many options for this so
here this situation is actually a nice
situation analogous to computing the gcd
of two polynomials so this
subset actually is cut out by one of
your given polynomials so by simply
substituting
into your input system you will in
practice see which are your points there
are other ways to do it if that's not
the case you can actually compute using
ll
um
radar basis reduction a
if you just know the coordinates or
approximate coordinates of one point you
can find the irreducible component
that would be another way but in our
case
we actually know all the roots so and
it's cut out with an extra polynomial
which we also know so so it's a fairly
easy case
i think we probably should just thank
god